where are we see where i bade 669 we're
going to start we're in test number 5
section 7 problem number one problem
number one if K is a positive integer
divisible by three and if K is less than
60 what is the create greatest possible
value of K so it's a positive value
integer greater than greater than its
positive so it's greater than zero it's
divisible by three and it's less than 60
k is less than 60 60 is divisible by
three right three times 20 is 60 so any
if i subtract three from 60 that will
also be divisible by 60 so k is equal to
57 right k can't be 60 because it's less
than 60 and then the next one down is 57
and if you don't believe that three is
divisible into 57 three goes into 57 11
x 3 27 goes into it 19 times there you
go so Joyce is c57 if you haven't
learned this already the easiest way to
figure out if the number is visible by
57 add the digits so five plus seven is
12 1 plus two is three so if when you
add the digits the sum you get is
divisible by three then the original
number is also divisible by three so you
could actually have gone down the
choices but you don't want to waste too
much time on the first problem problem
to the letter H is symmetric with
respect to two different lines it showed
in the dotted lines in the figure above
which of the following is symmetric with
respect to at least two different lines
so when they talk about age they're
saying I find if I draw an H they draw
this line of symmetry here and that
means if I were to flip H over this way
I get the same thing if I were to flip
it over this line I get the same thing
it's like a mirror image on either side
right this Green Line is a mirror image
of this purple line and the other way is
true too if I have h this move part is
the mirror image of this brown part
along the horizontal axis if I were to
draw if this was the the axis of the
mirror image so which of the other
letters has it so it should be a letter
that looks the same
aim that could be kind of folded in half
either vertically or horizontally and if
we look at all the choices X is
definitely the answer because if you
have an X and if you have a vertical
line of symmetry notice that the
left-hand side is the mirror image of
the right-hand side or you can flip it
over right they look the same it almost
looks like a reflection of the other
side and similarly if you took it the
other way also you could flip it up and
down and they also look as the mirror
image none of the other letters have
that property next problem whoops invert
colors okay problem number three Bobby
receives two dollars for each tour he
does during the week plus a weekly
allowance of ten dollars if Bobby
receives no other money which of the
following expressions represents the
total dollar amount Bobby receives for a
week in which he does end chores so if
he does end chores how much money is he
going to get just from doing chores he
does end chores and how much does you
get perch or well he gets two dollars
times two so this is how much he gets
just from doing tours to n or n times
too and then how much is he going to get
even for you those zero chores we get he
gets a ten dollar allowance no matter
what far more than I ever got as a child
so what is the formula it's 2n plus 10
is the amount of money he gets and that
is choice D right n is the number of
chores gets two dollars per join you
gets ten dollars no matter what even if
n is zero even if it does no chores next
problem for the smallest squares in
figure a and figure B are all equal in
size if the area in a is 26 square
centimeters what is the area of figure
be so let's let me see if I can draw
this these figures so I'll use the line
tool so hey looks like let's see the end
of line there so let me draw a rectangle
so the rectangle looks like that
close enough and then there's another
rectangle that's like this see there's
roughly half like that it's like this
another rectangle like this oh man the
drawing is the hardest part type my
shaky hands okay almost there I think
you get the point I'll try my best gotta
give me credit ok so that's figure a and
the figure B looks like this see if
horizontal line and then a vertical line
like that and then c is like that
connect these two and then oh boy so
tiring I have a line like that then it
gets split roughly in half over there
then this connects like that that
connects like that and then I have a
line like that so what they are telling
us is in figure a whoops I don't want to
do that edit undo what they're saying is
figure a each of these squares are the
same size of each of these squares in
Figure B and they also tell us that
figure a is 26 square centimeters so the
area is 26 centimeters squared so we
want to figure out the the area of me we
have to just figure out how big is each
of these little tiles right so how many
tiles are na let's count them one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen thirteen tiles
and they're 26 centimeters cubed total
right so if 13 times the area of a tile
is equal to 26 centimeters at i'll
divide both sides by 13 is two
centimeters squared right each tile is 2
centimeter squared and how many tiles
does behalf well one two three four five
six seven eight it has eight
so it's area is eight times the number
of tiles or the area of the tiles and we
know what the area of the tiles are it's
too because it's the same as a so area
is equal to 8 times 2 which is equal to
16 centimeters squared which is choice C
next problem more drawing for Sal Oh
boys the it's the drawing that really
tires me ok and I gotta draw it pretty
accurately because otherwise this is all
about reading a graph that's all right
so let me draw if I let me make the
first one in so Albert goes to like 300
that's 300 and then it's 150 which is
roughly half of that 150 like that and
then the other next guy is like a little
over 200 s it's like two thirds like I
don't know I'm just trying to my best
trying my best now the next guy gets it
like 250 there and then the last guy
I'll drag the white boxes is pretty much
the same number just like that and then
let me draw the other one in the other
so the other guy is 150 and this guy
gets to 250 which I said was roughly the
same amount asst is these guys over here
250 the next guy looks about the same
250 it's about that and this guy looks
like that all the work I'm doing now is
just to redraw what you already have
this guy it's like 350 it's like 300 or
something all right and if I were to
draw let me mark it off so this is 300
this is 150 see those guys that are a
little bit under 200 in between tune so
this is like 200
this is 250 they are asking us according
to the graph above which sales persons
had the greatest increase in the number
of units sold from nineteen eighty eight
to nineteen ninety nine so the ninety
nine eight nineteen eighty-eight ones
are the blue ones and 1999 are the red
ones so you're essentially saying who
had the greatest increase going from the
blue to the read write and this is
Albert this is Goldberg Patel this nice
inclusion Indian guy Smith Wang I look
forward to when they have a con in the
SATA anyway all right so who increased
the most going from the blue year
nineteen ninety eight to nineteen ninety
nine this guy clearly decreased right he
got one from 300 to 1 50 so it's not him
this guy decreased he went from
something larger to something smaller so
it's not him so what what the largest
increase well you could eyeball it right
where the increase is this guy had
whoops this guy increased this much
compared to a small increase here and a
small increase here so the answer is G
or Goldberg which is choice B see you
the next video